is 1928 in colombia
cruise ships are docked all along the
country's caribbean coast with american
tourists enjoying endless days in the
tropical sun but below the surface
trouble was brewing it all started with
25 000 workers who unlike the foreign
tourists had had enough of the sun the
heat and their never ending work these
men had been worked to the bone they had
no days off no medical care and their
salaries nothing more than scraps
they were sick of being treated like
slaves and in their minds it was time to
make their voices heard little did they
know what the consequences of that would
be
november 1928
thousands of workers go on strike they
refuse to work they gather in the
streets calling for their employers to
listen and no matter what their bosses
do they don't come back to work
the strike continues for two whole
months then finally the mayor of the
town gives in he calls for a gathering
with all the workers to discuss putting
an end to the strike
finally the workers think they've won
so thousands of colombian men women and
children gather in a town called cienega
waiting for the mayor to start
negotiations but he never does he didn't
invite them over to talk about working
conditions that was never the plan and
all those thousands of hopeful
colombians they had just walked straight
into an ambush as the sun sets below the
horizon the strikers get nervous wasn't
the mirror supposed to appear already
what was going on and that's when it
happens
a loud voice rips through the air people
disperse we will open fire
some other strikers disperse and flee
into the nights others decide to stand
their ground but what they didn't know
is that they were surrounded surrounded
by colombian soldiers deployed by the
president himself to make the problem go
away
seconds feel like hours in reality only
a minute passes between the soldiers
warning and the first shot going off
and what followed was a bloodbath
colombian soldiers with automatic
weapons opened fire on the people from
above the screaming and crying can be
heard from miles away as the colombian
military massacres its own people
between 50 and 2 000 people died that
nights but will never know the real
number because by sunrise only 9 bodies
are left in the town square one for each
of the workers demands the rest of the
bodies have been carted off and were
buried in mass graves that remain a
secret to this day
the bosses had gotten what they wanted
and the message was clear go on strike
and you die
but what had all this bloodshed been for
diamonds oil gold oh no thousands of
people had died over something far
simpler bananas
in the company that got the president to
order a massacre of its own people it
wasn't some evil colombian cartel it was
the united fruit company
yes an american banana company ordered
the massacre of its own workers for
almost 100 years the united fruit
company had the banana industry in a
chokehold for nearly a century it
controlled 90 of the banana markets and
everything the industry needed to get
those bananas from south america to the
us
we're talking trains boats land it was
all owned by this one company
by the early 1900s the united fruit
company or united fruits owned land and
almost every banana producing south
american central american and caribbean
country we're talking colombia guatemala
honduras jamaica they were all united
fruit territory and after just a few
decades united fruit has so much money
and so much land that they basically ran
the countries they were in presidents
dictators politicians all had to bow
down to their every whim even the
american government couldn't say no but
how how did a banana company of all
things accumulate so much power what was
it about a piece of yellow fruits that
could turn dictators into puppet leaders
and the leader of the free world into
just another yes man the answer as
always was money but to understand how
united fruit grew into one of the most
influential businesses in history we'll
have to travel back in time battle when
bananas weren't just a healthy breakfast
food but an exotic commodity that people
couldn't get enough of
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at
jaketren and you're automatically
entered a few of you have won already
watch out for fake accounts i will never
message you asking for money and this is
the united fruit
chiquita
company
and i've come to say bananas have to
ripen in a certain way when they're
flexed with brown and have a golden hue
bananas taste the best and are the best
for you
giant corporations like united fruit
have a lot of debts we don't know the
interest rate on the debts but what we
do know is that drowning in high
interest debt like credit cards really
holds you back in life but what if there
was a way out what if instead of being
shackled by high interest debt forever
you could get a new loan at a smarter
interest rates use that new loan to pay
off your high interest debts so you're
left with only one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff dates imagine the
weight that would be lifted off your
shoulders if you could do that well
you're in luck because that is where
upstart comes in upstart is a fast and
easy way to get a personal loan that
only requires one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff dates that you can
use to pay down your high interest debts
everything is done online with easy to
understand payment terms so you'll know
exactly how much you'll be paying and
for how long over 1.8 million people
have already used upstart to pay off
their credit cards funny personal
expense or consolidate high interest
debts the amazing thing about upstart is
that they consider factors other than
just your credit score upstart looks at
things like your income employment and
other information to get you a smarter
rate for your loan your loan offer could
range from 1 000 to 50 000
and you can check your rate in minutes
without hurting your credit score if you
end up getting a loan you can have
access to the funds in as little as one
business day you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score
right now by going to upstart.com jake
tran be sure to use my url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts would be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application that's up
stock.com jake tran to check your rate
today thanks to upstart for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
[Music]
this is miner c keith
back in the 1870s he was in charge of
building a railroad from the capital of
costa rica to one of its coastal points
unfortunately the costa rican government
ran out of money before the railroad was
completed so keith had to ask foreign
banks and investors to keep the project
going in exchange the costa rican
government gave keith a 99-year lease
for 800 000 acres of land when the
railroad was finally up and running
though keith ran into another problem he
didn't have enough passengers for the
rail to be profitable he didn't even
have enough passengers to cover his debt
to keep construction costs low heath had
been planting banana trees as a source
of food for his workers and that's when
a new idea struck him what if he could
import bananas to america
americans weren't used to eating these
yellow fruits on a daily basis but what
if they could be
from the very first shipment his
business plan was a massive success
now instead of waiting for passengers to
fill up trains he piled them high with
bananas on their way to eager north
americans and with all the land he got
from the costa rican government it
wasn't long before keith dominated the
banana industry but it didn't end there
this is lorenzo dao baker like keith
lorenzo also started importing bananas
to america in the 1870s only his bananas
came from jamaica both keith and
lorenzo's businesses were insanely
profitable but the two men realized
something even more important
together they could take their two
separate banana companies merge and
monopolize the entire industry
if they pull together their money they
could buy out every competitor and
become the biggest baddest banana
company on the planet
so that's exactly what they did so in
1899 keith and lorenzo's companies
merged to form the united fruit company
almost immediately united fruits started
buying out other banana exporters and
producers if they couldn't buy them out
they would buy as many shares in each
possible so that no matter who was
planting or exporting united fruit would
always profit
but it didn't end here either united
fruit wasn't just happy with controlling
the banana production industry they
wanted a cut of everything involved in
moving bananas from south america to the
us
so the company went on a buying spree
railroads trains ships and even
telegraph companies were acquired as
subsidiaries even the hospitals that
treated injured or sick workers were
owned by united fruit united fruit was
profiting from every single step in the
banana business and they had more money
than they knew what to do with but not
even this was enough they wanted more
control they wanted assurances that
their cash cow couldn't just be taken
away from them at a moment's notice and
to do that they'd have to climb even
higher on the ladder than ever before
right up to the presidents and
governments who ran the countries they
so easily exploited
[Music]
if there was one thing united fruit knew
well it was that money in a poor country
gives you limitless power after years of
being exploited by the spanish and then
going through endless wars after gaining
independence most south american central
american and caribbean countries were
really poor
so when the representatives of united
fruit came to south america dictators
and presidents offering massive amounts
of money in exchange for land it was an
easy yes
here were americans offering millions in
exchange for leasing land to plant
bananas what was the harmon accepting
plus once these banana farms were up and
running thousands of south americans
would be offered jobs it was a win-win
situation
or at least that's what they thought
whether united fruit bribed convinced or
threatened governments into selling them
land the end result was the same by 1930
the company owned over 3.5 million acres
in central america and the caribbean at
one point united fruit was the single
largest landowner in all of guatemala
and here's where things got interesting
with so much land under their control
united fruit basically had complete
control over the country's economy you
see united fruit could decide how many
workers to employ how much to pay them
and even how much money they wanted to
share with the country they occupied and
since there wasn't any land for
competitors or small businesses to use
no one could really stop united fruit
from demanding all sorts of concessions
in exchange for not tanking the economy
but here's the thing even if these
governments cooperated little to none of
the money united fruit made would ever
really make its way to the people
instead it all went to the foreign
investors and the company's owners it
was this total domination of south
american politics and economy by united
fruit that eventually led to these
countries being called banana republics
and with money power and influence on
the line the united fruit company didn't
care who it got into bed with they
worked with general rafael trujillo who
took control of the dominican republic
by force and murdered anyone who stood
in his way the samosa family of
nicaragua were just as bad marcos
jimenez the dictator of venezuela known
for his brutal secret police and
stealing more than 200 million dollars
from his own people and even miguel
mendes the president of colombia
responsible for the orders to kill the
banana workers in 1928.
with so much power and so little care
for the people and countries they were
exploiting the banana massacre of 1928
didn't come as much of a surprise
from gray in bogota colombia to
secretary of state in washington
december 5th 1928. i have been following
santa marta fruit strike through united
fruit company representative here also
through minister of foreign affairs who
on saturday told me government would
send additional troops and would arrest
all strike leaders and transport them to
prison at cartagena that government
would give adequate protection to
american interests involved
martial law was declared today i shall
see minister again in the morning and
report developments if any
december 6 1928
martial law and banana zone in santa
marta province declared by colombian
government last night demonstrations
against the government were held and
broken up by the few soldiers in santa
marta feeling against the government by
the proletariat which is shared by some
of the soldiers is high and it is
doubtful if we can depend upon the
colombian government for protection
may i respectfully suggest that my
request for the presence within calling
distance of an american warship be
granted and that it stand off subject to
my call and that the united fruit
company wireless stations in santa marta
call letters uj be used as we are
without telegraphic communication and
there is no other means of communication
with santa marta it is admitted that the
character of the strike has changed and
that the disturbance is a manifestation
with a subversive tendency december 7th
1928
situation outside santa marta city
unquestionably very serious outside zone
is in revolt military who have orders
not to spare ammunition have already
killed and wounded about 50 strikers
however i have now before me original
telegram sent today from governor to the
president saying santa marta city
completely quiet and railroad traffic
restored as far as cnn got
government now talks of general
offensive against strikers as soon as
all troop ships now on the way arrive
early next week
i'm concerned about some 20 americans
still in outside zone hope to learn they
are in safety before any much offensive
begins in view of danger otherwise of
possible repercussions on them
december 7th
1928 the legislation at pagoda reports
that categorical orders have been given
the local authorities at santa marta to
protect all american interests the
department does not repeat not desire to
send a warship to santa marta keep the
department informed of all developments
by telegraph
december 9th 1928
troop train from banana zone just
arrived in santa marta with all american
citizens no americans killed or wounded
guerilla warfare now continuing in the
zone but military forces are actively
engaged in clearing the district of the
communists as all danger to american
citizens is now passed i shall not
continue to report by cable unless you
wish me to do otherwise
december 11th 1928
referring to my recent reports
concerning the strike of the banana
workers in the santa marta district and
with special reference to my telegram
number 187 of december 10th 5 pm on that
subject i have the honor to report that
according to the latest information made
public the number of strikers killed by
the military forces during the recent
disturbances was something over 100
while the wounded reached 238
december 29th 1928
i have the honor to report that the
legal advisor of the united fruit
company here in pagoda stated yesterday
that the total number of strikers killed
by the colombian military authorities
during the recent disturbances reached
between five and six hundred while the
number of soldiers killed was one your
obedient servant jefferson gaffery
january 16 1929
i have the honor to report that the
pagoda representative of the united
fruit company told me yesterday that the
total number of strikers killed by the
colombian military exceeded one thousand
june 8 1929
i have the honor to report that the
manifestations against the government of
yesterday and the day before were
conspicuous for the number of
inscriptions carried by manifestants
relating to the fruit workers strike
denouncing the government and especially
general cortes vargas for the manner in
which the strike was put down also
skeletons and skulls adorned with
bunches of bananas were freely displayed
all the colombian strikers had wanted
was fair work conditions insurance
compensation for workplace accidents
clean dormitories one day off a week a
minimum pay rate and better hospital
services but for the united fruit
company this was as good as treason
punishable only by death there was only
one problem the massacre in colombia had
damaged their reputation bananas were
supposed to be healthy delicious
guilt-free fruit brought from a tropical
paradise no one wanted blood bananas so
to reinvent its public image united
fruit made a really weird investment it
created the biggest privately owned
fleet of ships in existence
in the late 1920s united fruit launched
its most impressive pr campaign yet they
created the great white fleet dozens of
white steam ships designed to carry
bananas and people between the u.s and
south america and the caribbean you see
to make up for all the rumors of
banana-related deaths united fruit had
to do a little rebranding so they
started taking passengers on banana
cruises these cruises would transport
americans from their cold grey cities
and towns to the warm bright happy
islands and countries controlled by
united fruit the cruises were designed
to get everyday americans to see that
wow the bananas i eat come from such a
happy ethical place they painted a
picture of a tropical paradise where
workers loved planting and harvesting
bananas almost as much as americans
loved eating them tours of plantations
would specifically visit areas that were
set up like a movie scene with smiling
workers in the background looking like
they're having the time of their life
all the while the real exploitation
happened behind the scenes decades later
north korea would take a page out of
united fruits book with their curated
tours of north korea and as unbelievable
as it may sound today
it worked by having americans give
first-hand accounts of the exotic and
mysterious lands the bananas came from
and how happy the locals were united
fruit managed to fool its biggest market
into believing they were the good guys
by buying bananas they weren't just
making united fruit rich they were
helping poor uneducated people live
better lives or at least that's what
united fruit wanted them to think
[Music]
by the early 1950s united fruit was
peaking it controlled millions of acres
of land it was worth millions of dollars
and there seemed to be no end to the
global demand for bananas almost every
major politician and lobbyist in america
owned shares in united fruit which meant
not even the american government would
lift a finger to stop their ruthless
climb to the top but then they ran into
trouble you see for years united fruit
had been using the guatemalan land it
owned as a way to control the guatemalan
government they didn't use or need all
that land to grow bananas so instead
they kept it as a sort of bargaining
chip something to hang over the
government's head and remind them who
really held all the power
but then jacobo r benz became president
in 1951 and suddenly all of their power
and control was under threat jacobo
arbenz was a devoted nationalist so for
him a foreign company owning the
majority of guatemalan land didn't sit
right so he announced a new plan every
acre of unused land united fruit owned
would be seized and redistributed to the
poor for years poor farmers had been
suffering with no land to grow their
crops and no way to make money
no more with our benson power all that
empty foreign land would be given back
to the people our bens even offered to
pay united fruit the
thousand dollars that they had said the
land was worth on their tax evaluation
but united fruit wanted none of it to
united fruit this was an act of war
their power money and future relied on a
monopoly where no one could compete with
their banana production what would
happen if some poor farmer suddenly
started his own banana company oh no
this our ben's guy had to go luckily for
united fruit they had some friends in
very high places and with dwight
eisenhower officially becoming president
of america in 1953 the company finally
saw their chance to bring a little
regime change to the guatemalan
government under eisenhower two men
would rise to power who would change the
history of not just guatemala but dozens
of other countries forever these two men
were john and alan doles
john doles the new secretary of state
had actually helped united fruit create
its guatemalan land monopoly and his
brother alan as the new director of the
cia he was in the perfect position to
further united fruits interests even
america's ambassador to the un owned a
massive amount of united fruit stock
translation decision makers in the u.s
government had a lot to lose if
guatemala seized all that banana land
from united fruit so just like the cia
had done in iran the year before in 1954
eisenhower approved operation pb success
it started by painting jacobo arbenz as
a communist and causing chaos among the
guatemalan people a few months later
carlos castillo armas invaded with the
backing of cia training weapons and
money in the violence and confusion that
followed the cia helped him gain the
support of many guatemalans even though
none of them really knew who he was
operation pb success just like its name
was a success with a weak army and the
people in uprising jacobo arbenz was
forced to resign and america's puppet
armas happily took his place
the united fruit company had just gotten
the american government to do their
dirty work for them who cared if the new
president was assassinated just three
years after taking power or that he was
succeeded by dictator after dictator
armas had served his purpose and united
fruit had gotten what they wanted they
had convinced the american government to
overthrow a democratically elected
president all in the name of banana
profits but even that one last after the
guatemalan coup united fruits revenue
slowly started to decline it got so bad
by 1972 the company had to sell the last
of the land it owned in guatemala to
stay in business
in the end it had all been for nothing
united fruit was forced into mergers and
eventually re-emerged as chiquita brands
international which you can find in your
local grocery store to this day
[Music]
today chiquita brands controls around 29
of the global banana market they're
still the biggest banana producer out
there and even though they don't have as
big of a monopoly as they used to
there's one thing that never changed
their willingness to commit crimes in
the name of profit
in 2007 chiquita brands pled guilty to
paying a designated colombian terrorist
organization 1.7 million dollars in
exchange for chiquita keeping its land
in operations in colombia the company
has also been accused of helping these
terrorist organizations smuggle drugs
and guns around the world in exchange
for protection
even in the 21st century even with the
rebranding chiquita brand still sticks
to their united fruit traditions
the cia coup in guatemala was based on
the strategy of one of america's most
successful covert operations in history
operation ajax carried out just one year
before guatemala operation ajax had
caused the overthrow of a democratic
government in another country for almost
exactly the same reasons and that
country was iran for years iran had been
ruled by a king who answered directly to
the british government the king allowed
britain to take more than half of the
country's oil and oil revenue leaving
regular iranians dirt poor and without a
single say in how their country was run
just like america had puppet leaders
around the world the british had their
very own profitable puppet and
everything went just as planned
right until a guy by the name of
muhammad masadag became iran's new prime
minister you see mazdag wasn't like the
other iranian prime ministers before him
who were scared of the king or the
british and just did what they asked he
really loved the iranian people and
wanted to see them prosper
and just like our benz he decided that a
foreign government taking iranian
resources land and money for itself
didn't sit right
so he nationalized the iranian oil
industry he changed the rules so that
iran and not britain would make the most
money from iranian oil it was again an
act of war
except this time britain didn't have the
expertise to take masadeg out themselves
so they turned to america for help
with eisenhower as president it was as
easy as calling masadega communist and
almost immediately the cia sprang into
action just like in guatemala the cia
did everything in its power to paint
mossadeg as the bad guy to make the
people angry and confused and to
overthrow the only guy who genuinely had
iran's best interests at heart
operation ajax was a success but there
was something they overlooked no one in
the cia or the american government had
any idea what the consequences of this
coup would be because unlike in
guatemala the coup didn't just lead to a
little fighting in bloodshed it would
change the direction of history forever
this one american coup this one act of
aggression would sow the seeds of middle
eastern terror in fact the majority of
the violence the majority of the
bloodshed the majority of the acts of
terror against the west can be traced
back to this one single event the
american coup of 1953 in iran but here's
the thing a youtube video going in depth
into these touchy subjects would get
demonetized right away so instead we
just released it as a private
full-length documentary that's only
available to members of this channel
it's already been age restricted and
members have been loving it
all you have to do to watch this
documentary right now is hit the join
button below once you sign up you'll
also have unlimited access to all our
other documentaries on the release of
the bin laden papers every jep steen mk
ultra the cia's mind control project
monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply and much more in the
future it's the kind of stuff they
should be teaching you in university
about how the world works but unlike
university you get all of this for just
five dollars a month and there's a
refund policy too unlike most youtube
memberships so if you're joining you
don't think it's worth it email us
within your first month of joining and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month there
is no refund because a few bad apples
decide to abuse this refund policy pause
the video and click that join button
below right now
this story still boggles my mind every
single time i go over it so let me know
what you guys thought in the comments
below and if you're new here my name is
jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so if you
enjoyed this one click that subscribe
button below for more videos just like
this multiple times every single week
for free remember you can follow me on
instagram for a chance to win a thousand
dollars at jtran not sure how much
longer i'm going to be running this
giveaway so get in there while you can
but that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you